the most beautiful dreams of freedom
are in prison
[Music]
the joke loses everything when the joker
laughs at himself
what is contrary to nature
never leads to good
simplicity
is the result of maturity
[Music]
to save all
we must risk all
every true genius
is bound to be naive
keep true to the dreams of thy youth
live with your century
but do not be its creature
be noble-minded
our own heart and not other men's
opinions of us
forms our true honor
[Music]
it is not flesh and blood
but heart which makes us fathers and
sons
[Music]
the voice of the majority
is no proof of justice
when the wine goes in
strange things come out
truth exists for the wise
beauty for the feeling heart
the iron chain and the silken cord are
both equally bonds
grace is the beauty of form
under the influence of freedom
[Music]
deeper meaning resides in the fairy
tales told me
in my childhood
than any truth that is taught in life
disappointments are to the soul
what a thunderstorm is to the air
[Music]
on the mountains
there is freedom
the world is perfect everywhere
save where man comes with his torment
god helps the brave
[Music]
all powerful souls have kindered with
each other
the dignity of mankind is in your hands
protect it
it sinks with you
with you it will ascend
[Music]
man is never so authentically himself
than when at play
while the gods remained more human
the men were more divine
man one may say
was never in such a completely animal
condition
but he has on the other hand
never escaped from it
mankind is made great or little
by its own will
the man of courage thinks not of himself
help the oppressed
and put thy trust in god
[Music]
there is no such thing as chance
and what seems to us more accidents
springs from the deepest source of
destiny
who reflects too much will accomplish
little
[Music]
when i hate i rob myself of something
but when i love
i become richer by the object i love
[Music]
did you think the lion was sleeping
because he didn't roar
the future comes slowly
the present flies
and the past stands still forever
[Music]
death is not too high a price for this
this taste of heaven
[Music]
who dares nothing
needs hope for nothing
it is a ring that makes a marriage
and it is from rings that chains are
made
misanthropy
is a slow suicide
freedom's sweet birthright they receive
again
under the mystic sway of holy might
brief is the sorrow
endless is the joy
basically indeed they may behave to us
but they cannot debase us
[Music]
art is gay
and life is earnest
he who considers too much
will perform little
the poet is the only true human being
and the best philosopher is only a
caricature in comparison
man is reflected in his actions
only he can love goodness who is able
with all his heart
to hate evil
uncompromisingly
[Music]
love is the only thing in nature
where even the power of the imagination
does not find a bottom
and does not see a limit
love and hunger
rule the world
[Music]
love gives forever
selfishness gives only in debt
the more sin
the less shame
only he who controls himself is free
great souls endure suffering in silence
voice should be weighed
not counted
[Music]
if someone asks me
why there is no religion in my heart
i will answer that i have lost it
through the fault of religion itself
what is not forbidden
is allowed
the worst person among people
is a person without aspirations
[Music]
there are no bad roles for good actors
[Music]
only a fool regrets that he has grown
old
a smart one enjoys wisdom
the body is created by the mind
[Music]
the fool is the only one who leaves the
matter halfway and looks
with his mouth open
from the side
what will come of all of this
three things you can't get back
time
word
and opportunity
i suppose i would be a good christian
but the church did everything to turn me
into a complete atheist
the world is small
but the human brain is immense
[Music]
man grows
as his goals grow
[Music]
you